vraiment les problèmes de leur histoire
sur les toits 8 profiter de rien en
définitive la [ __ ] j'me suis fait
flasher mes journées en ce moment tu
sais que les serveuses faux paquets
baiser fois ci les pays
je vous assure tout le monde sera payé
la nuit même suggéré this we aussi japon
quand tu veux te dis pas non plus tôt oh
là là haut ça faisait longtemps et donc
tu crois que les gens nous voient comme
ça bah oui j'imagine les moines gifle
que comme ça on saura si c'est vraiment
nous reconnaît vraiment dans la merde là
il ya deux solutions soit on est en 86
soit on est à l'ancienne
prenant 86 en ligne en cela c'est ma
femme c'est un public
t'es pas jaloux toi chérie kate pippa on
est trois à six mois faire de vieux os
si tu fais pas je me coiffe veut tout
faire mine oui on voudrait voir monsieur
claude berri le producteur de cinéma on
a une
enfin plusieurs super idée de scénario à
lui proposer premier des scénarios c'est
un gars qui travaille à la poste dans le
sud pour le punir on va le muté dans le
nord de la france
là oui je crois là où il fait froid sur
le temps c'est kelly dan disent les
cheveux à la place dès que
alors lé dakor difficile et pas majeur
mon fils est un loubard paniqué on fait
ça on échange nous lui
il est où eric r ça fait grand ça fait
le mur ils voulaient des dons au cul
souvent je suis parfait désolé de vous
dire j'ai avec votre fille et ma femme
techniquement tout s'est joué dans
l'escalier d'un quart à ce qu'ils
appellent leur passage et tout sur ça
j'ai vu les visiteurs et les visiteurs
de donc j'ai perdu les eaux je sais je
pars est très jeune mais je suis une
école
à
chemin